that attack me this guy's a joke artist
and this guy's a liar the fruit salad of
their life is what I would look at
now in regard to same-sex marriage I
don't favor it look the court is ruled
and I've moved on if they have not
committed a crime I'd make them pay a
fine some back taxes maybe some
community service and at the end I give
them a path to legalization but not a
path to citizenship I would repeal
Obamacare I would take some of the
federal resources combined it with a
freed up Medicaid program which I would
send back to the state
I inherited an eight billion dollar hole
in Ohio I have tax cuts the biggest of
any governor in the country and we have
a fiscal plan now we have a two billion
dollar surplus our credit is strong our
pensions are strong